PROFESSOR: In most of our
calculations of safety,
we're going to be interested
in the steady state
average transmission rate
between individuals in a room,
after the aerosol particles
have built up to a steady state.
But let's briefly talk
about the transient buildup,
and how to take
that into account,
just as an aside
in this board here.
So here is the
general expression
for the transmission
rate that we describe,
which depends on the
breathing rate squared,
the volume of the room.
It's an integral over
all the different drop
sizes, where NQ is a
lumped distribution
of the number of infection
quanta per volume per radius.
And then PM is the mass
transmission factor,
which depends on radius.
And lambda C is the
total relaxation rate
involving sedimentation
or settling and viral
deactivation and filtration.
And that also depends,
of course, on R.
And that lambda C of R also
ends up in the exponent here.
So that actually, that
rate of relaxation
of the concentration
in the air, is also
setting the time scale,
lambda C inverse,
for the buildup of those
aerosol droplets in the air.
And so that's this factor here.
This is basically the
transient term is this term.
And then this term, the
one, is the steady term.
So we're interested now what's
the effect of the transient.
Now, before we get to that, if
we forget about the transient
now, and we just have
the steady state,
then we introduce
beta bar as the sort
of constant steady state
value transmission.
And through this definition
here, by doing these integrals,
we have defined an
effective radius R bar,
which is sort of where you
evaluate the mass transmission
factor, and also the
filtration-- or the relaxation
rate in order to make
these two values equal.
So that's actually our
definition of effective radius.
And so now, looking
at the transient term,
let's ask ourselves, what
is the average transmission
rate up to a certain time tau.
So that would be, we
divide by a time tau,
and we ask ourselves
up to that time,
what is the average
transmission rate?
So we integrate beta dT from
0 to tau, then divide by tau.
So what would that be?
Well, we can take
this time integral
and bring it inside
the radius integral,
and write this as QB
squared over B integral 0
to infinity of PM
squared NQ of lambda C.
Keep in mind all those
factors depend on R. Times,
now, an integral from 0 to tau--
so I'll put this in brackets--
of 1 minus e to the minus
lambda C, which depends on R,
times T divided by
divided by tau dT.
And then dR.
So switching the order of
integration, where we're going
to do the time integral first.
And so what we have here,
if we just look only
at this expression
right here, we
can write this as a sum
of a steady state term.
So when it's just 1, this is
the integral 1 over tau from 0
to tau, so that's just 1.
So that's the steady
state contribution.
1 plus, and there's a
transient contribution where I
have to do this integral here.
So that's e to the
minus lambda C of T
over lambda C tau,
evaluated from 0 to tau.
And so we'll come back
to this in just a moment
and evaluate that.
But just to draw a
picture maybe first
of what we're looking at here.
The average transmission rate
as a function of this averaging
time tau, well,
eventually of course,
it tends to the
steady state value.
But it does so in a certain
way we're going to calculate,
like that, where the time
for that transmission--
or for that transition, is the
inverse of the relaxation time.
Although there's not a
precise value of that.
But if we want to keep
actually a scale for it,
it's going to be evaluate at that
value R bar that I mentioned.
That gives you a rough sense
of the overall relaxation.
So this build up of the aerosol
concentration in the room
once the infected
person has entered,
and eventually, there's sort
of a steady transmission rate
to everyone else in the room.
So let's continue calculating
this right here now.
So this is the transient.
And I can write this as 1.
And if I evaluate here, I can
put it this way, as minus,
and then I evaluate first at
the lower limit, which gives me
another 1, minus,
and then evaluating
at the upper limit, which is
tau, e to the minus lambda
C tau over lambda C tau.
And now, I'll use
an approximation
that helps me get a
simple analytical results.
So I should mention,
as soon as we
have exponential and
polynomial factors,
it can be difficult
to solve equations.
For example, what is the
bound on the occupancy
or the time in the room,
or the ventilation.
We like to get a simple formula.
And so if there's a nice
approximation I can make,
which is that 1 minus
e to the minus x over x
is not too far off from 1
over 1 plus x, it turns out.
So it's not a perfect match.
You can try plotting
these two functions.
But it's a reasonable
approximation,
given that everything we're
doing in this calculation,
when applied to
a real situation,
is going to be off by
some uncertainty, which
could be a factor of 2
or 3, this is actually
going to be more
than good enough
of an approximation for us.
So if I make that approximation,
then what I have here
is that this thing is
1 over 1 plus x here.
And so we end up with 1 minus
1 over 1 plus lambda C tau.
And when I combine
those two terms,
I end up with lambda C tau
over 1 plus lambda C tau.
So this is my approximation.
In fact, I can
further then write
that as 1 over 1 plus
lambda C tau inverse,
dividing the numerator and
denominator by lambda C tau.
So I'm just making some
approximations here
that allow me to get a
very simple expression
in the end for my
safety guideline,
taking into account this
transient build up here.
So remember that
the bound we have
is on the indoor
reproductive number, which
is N minus 1 times the
integral to tau of beta dT.
So what is that?
That's just the sort of
time average beta times tau.
So this bound is
actually N minus 1,
time average beta times tau.
And then our
guideline, of course,
is to make this less than
our tolerance, epsilon.
And so what that means
then is using this result,
you can see that I
just get the rest--
so if I look at the
expression for beta bracket,
it's just the steady state
expression times this factor.
So basically, this is
kind of the factor that
corrects for transient effects.
Again, with just a
simple approximation.
So I can then write
that my guideline now
has a modified form, which
is that N minus 1 times tau
is less than epsilon
over the time average
beta up to time tau.
And this is approximately
equal to epsilon over
beta steady state
times this factor here.
If I multiply that to the
other side, I just get 1 plus 1
over lambda C of R bar tau.
So basically, this right here
is the transient correction,
or modification.
And this is the
steady state formula,
which we will more
typically be using.
Now, why do we care
about the transient?
Well, first of all, you can see
that by using the transient,
we are being less conservative.
So if we want to be
very conservative,
we can say, you know
what, let's just
assume the second that
the infected person enters
the room, boom,
the transition rate
goes right to the maximum value.
That's the most conservative.
So generally, using the steady
state is more conservative.
So that's one reason
we like to use it.
Also, it gives you
a simpler formula.
Why add a bunch of
factors to a formula that
only make it less conservative.
And we've made a lot of
assumptions in this model,
so it makes sense, maybe
let's not worry about it.
However, I do actually
like to include it
for certain examples,
because it allows
you to capture the
intuition we all have
that when the time goes
to 0, the risk also
has to go to 0, which you
don't get from a steady state.
If this bumps up
right away, then you
could be spending like
2 seconds in a room,
and you have a chance of getting
infected right away, which
is actually not right.
There has to be some time
physically for transmission
to happen through these droplets
from one person to another.
So the effect of the transient
correction, as you can see here
is, when lambda C tau
is larger than 1--
so that's times that are kind
of out here-- that term is gone.
But when you get to these
earlier times, or very short
times, where there
hasn't been time yet
for the build up of the airborne
concentration, then as you see,
as tau goes is 0 actually,
this term diverges.
So what actually happens
is that if I calculate sort
of, for example, one thing you
can get from this guideline
is what is the sort of maximum
occupancy, or versus time.
Or it's sort of the maximum
time in the room for a given
occupancy.
We're going to be looking
at lots of plots like this.
I would have something
that might look like this
for steady transmission.
And when this time
gets larger then lambda
C of R bar inverse--
there's some critical
time scale there,
which is this one right here--
then when you're
past that time scale,
you've got the steady state.
But if you go to smaller times,
then what happens at this thing
can sort of blow
up a lot faster.
So what it kind of
helps to capture
is, again, this intuition
that if I put in like tau
is extremely small, then of
course, the risk goes away,
and I can have larger numbers
of people in the room,
or I can tolerate smaller
times and actually be safe.
So anyway, that's one
reason we do that.
On the other hand, for a
conservative guideline,
and the most important
message of this course,
really, is to think about
that steady state transmission
rate, which we will
mainly be focusing
on in all of our examples.